welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and vibranium's deadly value in the
MCU is about to get tested in a big way
with the latest episode of She-Hulk
revealing the Intelligentsia lab is
prepping a hulk-sized syringe probably
made out of vibranium and black panther
workout at Forever is exclusive footage
from the d23 proving new details about
vibranium that make it especially
worrisome or especially cool Marvel
phase 4 is looking like it will end with
that over a resource with implications
ranging as far as the composition of
anti-hulk bullets cap Shields Iron Heart
suits and Magneto blockers episode 6 of
She-Hulk Ends by confirming the
Intelligentsia which is more than just a
troll website it's actually a front
powered by a well-funded lab with far
greater reach literally spying on Jen
Walters when she should have been in
private and developing new ouchies to
pierce her skin to steal her blood now
the MCU version of the intelligencia
will likely have some membership similar
to that in the comics like the leader in
Modoc and like in the comics might have
a red Hulk plot in the works but this is
actually not the first time the
Intelligentsia has come up in the MCU
Avengers Age of Ultron showed a dossier
for Ulysses claw listing him as a former
member of the intelligencia and claw's
role as a vibranium dealer I think had a
lot to do with what is going on with the
intelligencia now well that thought but
the sighting of that bent needle in this
intelligency lab proves that this
organization was behind The Wrecking
Crew who attacked Jen in episode three
Thunderball did you get it no once you
turned into She-Hulk I couldn't Pierce
that nasty green skin damn it Paul's
gonna be mad there's a very good chance
that this site's mod hulk King is
actually Todd Todd the mod remember Todd
Jen's date in episode 4 with a weird
obsession with her powers is it true are
you indestructible I mean I haven't
really tested it out well what about
super speed night vision impenetrable
skin yeah my skin is impenetrable at
least with anything on Earth even
vibranium God you're just so powerful
what a specimen Todd made a surprise
return in episode 5 as one of Mallory's
clients I didn't know you worked here
yeah are you a client I am I'm one of
the biggest just had a meeting with my
favorite lady lawyer no touching yeah we
should reconnect soon yeah absolutely
that would be great yeah drinks on me so
really it's all lining up Todd is likely
the Wormy creator of the intelligencia
website the public face in front of a
darker intelligency organization
hell-bent on acquiring she-hulk's blood
probably to launch their own Hulk Red
Hulk or a different one and I know this
has all been covered in like 80 episodes
of the break room at this point but if
you really want to get into the
conspiracy of it all the heavy drinking
Jen does throughout the series may be
part of this plot I pointed out before
how Mr Holloway in episode 2 buys Jen a
glass of not just any bourbon but Pappy
Van Winkle 23 year old aged bourbon only
a few thousand of these bottles exists
in the world each of them costing over
five thousand dollars per bottle and if
you think about it every episode of the
series has featured Jen at a bar
drinking to excess like it is wild how
many of the into the series of required
Tatiana maslani to play drunk or
hungover and in the latest wedding
episode she gets drunk again at that
wedding cash bar you know how committed
to drinking gotta be to get drunk at a
cash bar and she cozies up with Josh
which is where an intelligent see a
hidden camera spies on her so yeah when
Todd says drinks on me and slurps
through his straw like he's drinking her
milkshake
does it not feel like all of these
drinks being offered to Jen are coming
from the same group of guys trying to
get her DNA from her glasses anyway when
Todd asked Jen if vibranium could Pierce
her skin he said that he wished he had
some to try and that seemed pretty
genuine Jen responds that no metal on
Earth can Pierce her skin but remember
Earth's Supply vibranium came from a
meteorite from outer space that struck
wakanda in ancient times this is an
extraterrestrial metal with unique
properties and I think this big boy
syringe in the final shot of episode 6
is made of vibranium or maybe some kind
of vibranium alloy like Proto adamantium
or maybe something else off world like
for reverence MCU metals like uru are
what Stormbreaker and thanos's sword are
made out of and those are native
Valerian and might be able to pierce
Hulk's skin now if you watch into
fantasy you start getting real obsessed
with Bloodlines if you want to lay a
claim to a kingdom having the right
lineage is key for most of us our actual
real-life Bloodlines have nothing to do
with royalty but you can fill that Gap
in your heritage by making your own
bloodline in bloodline a free mobile
game on IOS and Android bloodline takes
place in an awesome fantasy world with
amazing Graphics you'll choose Champions
find Companions and raise powerful
Offspring you can customize your
Champions by marrying different
Bloodlines and building out your family
tree until you find the perfect combo of
abilities to suit your gameplay style
the Bloodlines are so cool there are the
werewolf assassin likeness the
dragonborns of carg who can naturally
turn into real dragons in the demigods
of fulgar my favorite since they have
the best area of effect skills and I
like letting everybody know how badass I
am if you can't wait to start making a
unique lineage of your own then download
bloodline by using my link or scanning
the QR code and you'll get a super rare
half Dragonborn half demigod hybrid
error for free you'll also get an
exclusive starter pack worth twenty
dollars that has 100 000 gold 20
intimacy packs and 100 diamonds just
scan the QR code or click the link in
the description to get started with
bloodline but I think it's interesting
how all this is coming out around the
same time d23 unveiled exclusive footage
of black panther were kind of forever
that confirmed that vibranium does not
set off metal detectors Queen ramonda is
grilled by delegates at the U.N
including Richard Schiff as the American
delegate and a French delegate who says
that wakanda could use vibranium to
create weapons of mass destruction that
do not set off metal detectors now if
you remember in the 2018 black panther
film we actually saw this win to
Charlotte Nakia in Okoye entered the
Korean club and they pass through metal
detectors without setting them off
despite being covered in vibranium but
here and again here it's just a reminder
that vibranium as a medal not originally
from this planet has unique properties
that really defy the laws of physics
magnetism everything as in there's a
kind of magic to them magic or what the
asgardians would call science so what
changed over the intelligency recently
that allows them to now have access to
what we assume is a vibranium needle to
test out on She-Hulk well it seems like
black panther will kind of forever will
be a war fought over vibranium what kind
of controls the bulk of the world supply
of vibranium and now Western governments
like French Commandos are raiding
wakanda and outrage centers in Mali to
try to steal it I believe that when that
meteorite crashed into Earth an
additional chunk of vibrating broke off
and landed somewhere in the ocean which
is what allowed the people living in
swallow Khan to adapt at an advanced
Pace to form this Kingdom that now
rivals wakanda in trailer footage from
wakada Forever shows a human covert
Expedition involving deep sea divers and
armed private soldiers that's never a
good sign I think this is a mission to
steal vibranium from the people of Namor
and now I think this Expedition is being
funded by members of the Intelligentsia
in the past the MCU intelligencia was
supplied vibranium by claw but ever
since killmonger killed cloth their
supply has been cut off and now in this
post-blip world the power structure has
changed with power Brokers and such to
allow them new Pathways to find this
precious alien metal and I think that
very theft a vibranium will be what
forces Neymar to wakanda's front door
now we have yet to learn the exact
membership of the intelligencia or how
exactly they're organized in the MCU are
they a centralized membership consisting
of the leader Modoc and like Zemo or
something more decentralized in
Grassroots like a newsletter sent out
over the dark Web written by ultron's
disembodied Consciousness and God I hope
so that'd be awesome but truly the
intelligencia would be the perfect place
to introduce Dr Victor Von Doom who was
involved with the earliest lineup of the
intelligency in the comics he thwarted
the rest of them in their plot to
acquire the Lost Knowledge from the
Library of Alexandria so think about it
an intelligencia in the MCU led by Dr
Doom seeking ways to harvest vibranium
and weaponize his magical qualities
think of the applications bullets that
can actually kill hulks metallic weapons
that are immune to the electromagnetic
frequency that Magneto uses to
manipulate metal I mean this plot by the
intelligencia against Shield may be the
first steps in an eventual showdown
between Dr Doom and Magneto and Avengers
Secret Wars let me know your thoughts on
this Theory and follow me on Instagram
and Twitter and Tick Tock at eavos
follow new rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]